how come we're not if we're talking 70
000 right you're saying 70 000 in 2020
statistics came out that out of the 660
something thousand people this was
public info out of 661 000 people that
died from covid
five percent died with kobe being the
leading indicator so five percent of 660
you're talking about 33 000 people died
as a leading cause being coveted you're
talking 70 000 died last year leading
causing opioids
how come no one's calling the alarm how
come i don't see it on cnn fox msnbc
wise is are they afraid of bringing it
up or is everybody kind of like hush
hush because they're giving us money for
campaigns and commercials well there i
mean i mean some have been doing uh
documentaries on this i think there was
the forgotten epidemic i forget if it
was cnn or msnbc but understand that
when you have privately fund campaigns
that are routinely in the millions tens
of millions maybe hundreds of millions
these are
largely privately funded they mean
whether you're right or whether you're
left you are often getting corporate
donations or corporate interest group
donations
and when you have when you take
someone's money it's very difficult to
tell them no or to act contrary to their
interest
and these major
donors give to both sides so that
whoever ends up in power
they don't mess
well they don't mess with those that the
health care system which right now is
very lucrative and as you probably know
um the united states health care
industry is over three trillion dollars
a year um
by itself that's the fifth largest
economy in the in the world just that
just healthcare and what you also might
know is that
we live about the same
number of years as they do in greece
and they spend a third of that
per person
so it's not like the the cut the patient
in the united states is actually getting
a good return on on the cost so
we have a very expensive system that is
not giving us life expectancy in return
and we have a political system that is
often dependent on private donations and
so who when they make their whichever
side gets the money they don't mess with
this system and there are many calling
for reform i think it was it john mccain
who called for campaign finance reform
as well um
sort of getting the money out of
campaigns would then make candidates
more responsive to the needs of a
population as opposed to the needs of
you know corporate imperatives so if you
like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]